Okay, so I talked about memory,
I talked about isolation.
Transferring control
from user to OS part of
the system that we have, a memory
where OS coordinator structure is.
We want to sort of dig deeper into it
and really think about how do we define
what data and code a certain process or
application can access.
I said one of the jobs the operating
system has is give you high level
obstructions.
Okay, so we don't talked about
particular memory location that we
happen to have right now.
With each process we said sort
of can believe as if it has
the whole computer to itself.
In particular, each process wants
to feel that it has the memory
that it needs, where its data and
code is going to go, it has to itself.
And actually, each process does have
something of that sort for itself, and
that's called an Address Space.
Address Space is sort of a container.
It's a sequence of memory locations.
It's a collection,
which is a sequence of memory locations,
that define a collection of those memory
locations, it defines a space, and
each of this location can be address so
that's what makes it an address space.
because each process has an abstraction
of memory that is an Address Space,
an Address Space actually is going
to be a unit of isolation, so
when we talked about isolation.
Now we're talking about sort of
isolate what from what else, and
we're going to talk about
isolating Address Space.
Address Space completely defines
the data and code that is there for
a given application.
The data and code is going to reside
in the bunch of memory locations and
those memory locations together
make up an Address Space
that belongs to a particular process or
application.
So that's why we have to sort
of [INAUDIBLE] solation.
We have to dig deeper a little bit and
think about the Address Spaces.
So if a processes essentially going to
think that it has the memory to itself,
it's going to think of this memory as
a contiguous set of locations going from
some starting address zero to some max.
And it's going to think that it
has this set of memory locations,
not only the contiguous, but they could
even be more than the total memory
that we have, physical memory
that we have in a computer.
If you done your operating systems
class, you heard about virtual memory,
which most operating systems
actually support virtual memory.
That could be more than
the physical memory that we have.
Address Space that we're talking about,
when a process is a contiguous
container of memory, okay?
That can be addressed,
which is going from zero to some maximum
address that we can have and it doesn't
have to be constrained by the physical
amount of physical memory that we have.
So the address space actually usually,
it it's a 32-bit architecture,
basically means addresses in
that case are 32-bit long.
Or it could be 64-bit architecture.
In that case they'll be 64-bit long.
They go typically form zero through two
to the third minus to minus one, or
two to the 64 minus one.
Your addresses and number bits, and
based on that you can have two to
the n different locations that you can
address with that size of an address.
We said that Address Space
is a contender for
anything that has to be stored
in memory for a process.
Remember, process has to
fetch instruction data,
so that information has to be in
memory before we can execute it.
So we have to prepare
an Address Space for
a process before it starts execution.
And we tell the process,
here is an Address Space for
you, you can address the location
zero through something, and
you decide to put your data and
code in these locations.